Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. This week we're doing something a little bit different from our usual conversation with a psychologist about his or her thought-provoking research. Today I will be talking with a journalist and podcast host who has spent more than two decades bringing psychological and behavioral research to the public. Many of you probably know his work, especially if you subscribe to other science podcasts and if you listen regularly to national public radio.
您好，欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），本节目旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本周，我们将进行一些与以往不同的尝试，不再是与心理学家探讨其发人深省的研究，今天我将采访一位记者兼播客主持人，他花了二十多年时间向公众普及心理学和行为学研究。你们中的许多人可能熟悉他的作品，特别是如果你订阅了其他科学播客，或者经常收听国家公共广播电台（NPR）的话。
I'm talking about Shankar Vedantam, the host and executive editor of Hidden Brain, one of the most popular science podcasts in the U.S., which receives millions of downloads every week. Hidden Brain is also broadcast on more than 400 public radio stations across the country. Its mission is to explore the unconscious patterns that drive human behavior. Recent episodes have covered the psychology of money, the rise of rudeness and resilience in coping with grief, to name just a few topics. Shankar Vedantam has been reporting on human behavior and social science research for more than 25 years. He was National Public Radio's social science correspondent from 2011 until 2020. Before that, he spent 10 years as a reporter and columnist at the Washington.
我说的就是香卡·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam），他是美国最受欢迎的科学播客之一《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）的主持人兼执行编辑，该节目每周有数百万次的下载量。《隐藏的大脑》也在全国400多家公共广播电台播出。其使命是探索驱动人类行为的无意识模式。最近的节目涵盖了金钱心理学、粗鲁行为的兴起以及应对悲伤的韧性等，这仅仅是其中几个主题。香卡·维丹塔姆报道人类行为和社会科学研究已有25年多的历史。他曾于2011年至2020年担任国家公共广播电台的社会科学记者。在此之前，他在《华盛顿邮报》担任了10年的记者和专栏作家。
Post. He is the author of two nonfiction books, Useful Delusions, The Power and Paradox of the Self-Deceiving Brain, published in 2021, and The Hidden Brain, How Our Unconscious Minds Elect Presidents, Control Markets, Wage Wars, and Save Our Lives, Published in 2010. He has also written plays in a collection of short stories. And in the interest of full disclosure, I will tell you, APA has worked with Shankar over the years, occasionally referring him to expert psychologists as part of his reporting. Thank you for joining us today, Shankar. It's a pleasure, Kim.
他著有两本非虚构类书籍，分别是2021年出版的《有用的错觉：自欺大脑的力量与悖论》（Useful Delusions: The Power and Paradox of the Self-Deceiving Brain），以及2010年出版的《隐藏的大脑：我们的无意识思维如何选举总统、控制市场、发动战争并拯救我们的生命》（The Hidden Brain: How Our Unconscious Minds Elect Presidents, Control Markets, Wage Wars, and Save Our Lives）。他还写过剧本和短篇小说集。为了充分披露信息，我告诉大家，美国心理学会多年来一直与香卡合作，作为他报道的一部分，偶尔会向他推荐心理学专家。感谢您今天加入我们，香卡。很高兴见到你，金。
Thank you so much for having me today. Let's start with a little bit more about your story. One item from your CV that I didn't mention a moment ago was that you have an undergraduate degree in electronic engineering and a master's degree in journalism. How did you find your way to reporting on behavioral science and what has made you stick with it all these years? My background as an engineer helped me in some way,
非常感谢您今天的邀请。让我们从您的个人经历开始聊起。您的简历中有一项我刚才没提到的，就是您拥有电子工程学士学位和新闻学硕士学位。您是如何走上报道行为科学这条道路的，又是什么让您多年来一直坚持下去的？我的工程师背景在某种程度上帮助了我，
enter science journalism, Kim. It allowed me the ability to understand how scientific papers were being written. Many journalists are highly phobic of anything to do with mathematics. I found myself a little less so. And so I gravitated to science journalism almost from the start of my career. I was actually working at the Philadelphia Inquirer at the time, my first newspaper job. And I realized over, as I was working at the Inquirer, that some of the most fascinating questions in science had to do with the brain and the mind and human behavior. And so really, over a period of years, my interest gradually narrowed from covering all of science journalism to focusing predominantly on the mind and mental health. For about 10 years when I was working at the Washington Post,
让我进入了科学新闻领域，金。它让我有能力理解科学论文是如何撰写的。许多记者对任何与数学有关的东西都有强烈的恐惧感。我发现自己稍微好一点。因此，我从职业生涯之初就倾向于科学新闻。当时我实际上是在《费城问询报》工作，那是我的第一份报纸工作。在《问询报》工作期间，我意识到科学中最迷人的一些问题都与大脑、思维和人类行为有关。所以，在几年时间里，我的兴趣逐渐从涵盖所有科学新闻缩小到主要关注思维和心理健康。在大约10年的时间里，当我在《华盛顿邮报》工作时，
I focused a lot on mental health issues and psychiatry and covered the questions related to mental disorders and the treatment of mental disorders. And I would say subsequent to that, largely as a result of a column that I started writing in the Washington Post called Department of Human Behavior, I became increasingly interested in the world of the social psychology world, the worlds in which psychology speaks not just to disorder or illness, but the way in which psychology can address everyday problems that everyday people are having throughout their lives. So you started Hidden Brain at NPR, but a few years ago, you decided to open your own production company, Hidden Brain Media. Why did you decide to go out on your own and what can you do now as the boss and an entrepreneur that you couldn't do in your prior jobs?
我非常关注心理健康问题和精神病学，并报道了与精神障碍及其治疗相关的问题。我想说，此后，很大程度上是因为我在《华盛顿邮报》开始撰写一个名为“人类行为部”（Department of Human Behavior）的专栏，我开始对社会心理学领域产生越来越浓厚的兴趣，在这个领域中，心理学不仅探讨障碍或疾病，还探讨心理学如何解决普通人在生活中遇到的日常问题。那么，您在NPR创办了《隐藏的大脑》，但几年前，您决定开设自己的制作公司——Hidden Brain Media。您为什么决定单干？作为老板和企业家，您现在能做哪些以前在工作中做不到的事情？
Yeah, that's a great question, Kim. So I wrote the Hidden Brain book in 2009, 2010. It was published, I believe, in 2010. And I joined NPR in 2011. And so in some ways, NPR had seen the book that I had written about the hidden brain. and they were interested in my coming to NPR to explore those issues. So in some ways, the story of Hidden Brain really begins from before I joined NPR. For many years, while I was working at NPR, I would do short stories, usually on
是的，这是一个很好的问题，金。我在2009年、2010年写了《隐藏的大脑》这本书。我相信它是在2010年出版的。我于2011年加入NPR。所以在某种程度上，NPR看到了我写的关于隐藏大脑的书，他们对我加入NPR去探索这些问题很感兴趣。所以从某种意义上说，《隐藏的大脑》的故事实际上在我加入NPR之前就开始了。在NPR工作多年期间，我经常会做一些短篇报道，通常是在
Morning Edition, often in conversation with Stevenson, Kipp, or David Green, talking about interesting pieces of social science research, often psychology, but sometimes, you know, economics and political science and sociology. And then in 2015, partly because... those short stories, those short segments were proved to be very popular with listeners, we decided to try and launch a longer form version of those short stories, and that became the Hidden Brain podcast. The Hidden Brain had a wonderful run at NPR. The Hidden Brain radio show launched at NPR and continues to be distributed by NPR. But a couple of years ago, I decided
《早间版》（Morning Edition）节目中，经常与史蒂文森·基普（Stevenson Kipp）或大卫·格林（David Green）对话，谈论一些有趣的社会科学研究，通常是心理学，但有时也涉及经济学、政治学和社会学。然后在2015年，部分原因是……那些短篇故事和短片段被证明非常受听众欢迎，我们决定尝试推出这些短篇故事的长篇版本，这就是《隐藏的大脑》播客。《隐藏的大脑》在NPR运行得非常出色。《隐藏的大脑》广播节目在NPR推出，并继续由NPR发行。但几年前，我决定
that it would be helpful to, in some ways, explore the possibility. of what Hidden Brain could become outside the confines of a large media organization. And there were several reasons for that. But I would say chief among them was that the story of Hidden Brain really was not a story of the podcast. My interest in Hidden Brain, I would say, really began when I was working at the Washington Post in 2007 through 2009 when I was writing a weekly newspaper column. So I would argue that Hidden Brain's Genesis was really as a newspaper column. And then it became a book, and then it became, you know, short articles on the radio, and then it became a podcast. But to my mind, the interest that I have in Hidden Brain is not limited just to audio.
在某种程度上，探索《隐藏的大脑》在大型媒体机构之外的可能性会很有帮助。原因有几个。但我认为最主要的原因是，《隐藏的大脑》的故事实际上并不是播客的故事。我对《隐藏的大脑》的兴趣，可以说，真正始于2007年至2009年我在《华盛顿邮报》工作期间，当时我正在写每周的报纸专栏。所以我认为《隐藏的大脑》的起源实际上是一个报纸专栏。然后它变成了一本书，然后变成了广播里的短文章，最后变成了播客。但在我看来，我对《隐藏的大脑》的兴趣并不局限于音频。
I'm interested in the ways in which it can apply, you know, it can reach people in all kinds of different forums and different media. And becoming an independent organization is opening up all kinds of possibilities to make that happen, including, for example, exploring possibilities in television. We are actively considering what a Hidden Brain television. show could look like. We're actually actively thinking about what an event's practice could look like, where we're actually saying, you know, there are people who want the three-minute version of the story, there are people who want the 45-minute version of the story, but there are people who might want the three-week version of the story, people who have a deep interest in a subject, and how can we
我对它能以各种不同形式和不同媒体触及人们的方式很感兴趣。成为一个独立的组织正在开启各种可能性来实现这一目标，例如，探索电视领域的可能性。我们正在积极考虑《隐藏的大脑》电视节目会是什么样子。我们实际上也在积极思考活动实践会是什么样子，我们实际上是在说，你知道，有些人想要三分钟版本的故事，有些人想要45分钟版本的故事，但有些人可能想要三周版本的故事，那些对某个主题有浓厚兴趣的人，我们该如何
actually serve these different audiences? Being an entrepreneur has been a real learning experience. I like to say that I have sort of collected my street MBA, as it sometimes called, over the the last couple of years. But it's also been wonderful, not just in teaching me how to run a business and to employ people and to make sure that we can keep the lights on. All of those have been interesting experiences. It's also taught me a lot about myself and my own abilities and capacities in ways that it's been quite revealing. So the term hidden brain is one that you coined, and it has a particular meaning which some of our listeners might not fully understand. Can you explain what the term means and how you came up with it? Sure. As I said, the genesis of the Hidden Brain book
真正服务于这些不同的受众呢？成为一名企业家是一次真正的学习经历。我喜欢说，在过去几年里，我收集了所谓的“街头MBA”。但这也很棒，不仅教会了我如何经营企业、雇佣员工并确保我们能维持运营。所有这些都是有趣的经历。它也让我对自己和自己的能力有了很多了解，这种方式非常具有启发性。那么，“隐藏的大脑”这个词是您创造的，它有一个特定的含义，我们的一些听众可能并不完全理解。您能解释一下这个词的含义以及您是怎么想出这个词的吗？当然。正如我所说，《隐藏的大脑》这本书的起源
was this newspaper column I was writing at the Washington Post called Department of Human Behavior. It was a weekly column where I would try and link together things that were happening in the news, whether that was the war in Iraq or the presidential election or whatever was happening in the news with interesting social science research. And it was a fascinating experiment because each week I had to find interesting connections between things happening in the news and things that were in the world of academic psychology or the social sciences. But one of the things that I started to notice, of course, was that a lot of interesting work was being published that suggested that people did not really fully understand their own behavior
就是我在《华盛顿邮报》写的那个叫“人类行为部”的报纸专栏。这是一个每周专栏，我会尝试将新闻中发生的事情——无论是伊拉克战争、总统选举还是新闻中发生的任何事情——与有趣的社会科学研究联系起来。这是一个迷人的实验，因为每周我都必须在新闻中发生的事情与学术心理学或社会科学世界中的事物之间找到有趣的联系。但当然，我开始注意到的一件事是，许多有趣的研究被发表出来，表明人们并没有真正完全理解自己的行为
and motivations. And as someone who thinks of himself as being a very rational, deliberate, intentional person, I found this very surprising because I felt, well, other people might not know. their minds, but surely I know my mind and I know why I do the things that I do. I'm a very logical person. But over the course of writing this newspaper column at the Washington Post, I realized my intuition was in fact wrong, that in fact there was a vast amount of my own mind that was actually hidden from me. And some elements of what I eventually came to call the hidden brain are hidden by design. In other words, even if I try my best to access some
和动机。作为一个认为自己是一个非常理性、审慎、有意识的人，我发现这非常令人惊讶，因为我觉得，好吧，其他人可能不了解他们的思维，但我肯定了解我的思维，我知道我为什么做我所做的事情。我是一个非常合乎逻辑的人。但在《华盛顿邮报》撰写这个报纸专栏的过程中，我意识到我的直觉实际上是错误的，事实上，我自己的思维中有很大一部分实际上对我来说是隐藏的。我最终称之为“隐藏大脑”的某些元素是刻意隐藏的。换句话说，即使我尽我所能去接触
parts of my brain, they're basically permanently sealed off from introspection. But there are other aspects of the hidden brain that are just simply out of sight. You know, I'm not paying attention to them, even though if I tried and I made an effort to pay attention to them, I would be able to do so. So the hidden brain was really my term to pull together this range of things that were happening outside of my own conscious awareness that was, in fact, influencing my behavior, my judgment, my decisions. And I found that world fascinating. And to be honest, I still find that idea fascinating. I think it's one of the most revolutionary ideas I've come by in my own life, the idea that even though we feel as if we have a complete and full understanding of our own minds,
我大脑的某些部分，它们基本上是永久地与内省隔绝的。但“隐藏大脑”还有其他方面只是简单地看不见。你知道，我没有注意到它们，即使我尝试并努力去注意它们，我也能够做到。所以“隐藏大脑”确实是我用来概括这一系列发生在我意识之外、实际上正在影响我的行为、判断和决定的事物的术语。我发现那个世界很迷人。老实说，我仍然觉得这个想法很迷人。我认为这是我在自己生活中遇到的最革命性的想法之一，即尽管我们感觉自己对自己的思维有了完整和充分的理解，
our understanding is in fact fleeting and probably is not even the vast majority of our minds. In fact, the vast majority of our minds are probably hidden from us at any given time. Well, let's talk for a minute about where you get the ideas for your show. You've got a team of eight people right now working with you. Are you all reading scientific journals every day to generate ideas or listeners sending you ideas? what are you looking for and what makes for a great episode? Yeah, it's a great question. I have a wonderful team of people who've been working with me.
我们的理解实际上是短暂的，可能甚至不是我们思维的绝大部分。事实上，在任何特定时间，我们思维的绝大部分可能都对我们隐藏着。好吧，让我们花点时间谈谈您从哪里获得节目的创意。您现在有一个八人的团队与您一起工作。你们所有人每天都在阅读科学期刊来产生创意，还是听众给您发送创意？您在寻找什么，什么才是一期精彩的节目？是的，这是一个很好的问题。我有一个很棒的团队，他们一直和我一起工作。
Some of them have been working with me for many years. Some of them are new, incredibly talented people. Many of them are very, very skilled audio producers. As you probably gathered and putting together this podcast came, audio production turns out to be more complex than many people realize. It actually has many interesting elements to it, many nuances to it, and doing it well is not easy. So many people on my team are focused on audio production
他们中的一些人已经和我一起工作了很多年。他们中的一些人是新的、非常有才华的人。他们中的许多人是非常、非常熟练的音频制作人。正如您可能收集到的，制作这个播客，金，音频制作比许多人意识到的要复杂得多。它实际上有很多有趣的元素，有很多细微差别，而且做好它并不容易。所以我团队中的许多人都专注于音频制作
and thinking through the nuances of audio production. We do indeed have people working on the team who are also thinking about research and research insights. I myself, over the past 15 years, I would say, have made a daily practice of trying to read academic journals on a very regular basis. And in many ways, I think I read more voraciously than many people who are in the academy
并思考音频制作的细微差别。我们确实有团队成员也在思考研究和研究见解。我自己，在过去的15年里，我想说，已经养成了一种每天非常定期地阅读学术期刊的习惯。在很多方面，我认为我比许多在学术界的人阅读得更贪婪
because I don't limit myself to an individual feel. So I'm reading journals in psychology and sociology and economics and anthropology. I read very, very voraciously. And I also try and keep track of interesting articles that I come by. So for the past, I would say 15 years or so. Every time I come by an interesting article, I save the article. And then I have an internal sort of archiving system that allows me to go back and retrieve the article with a bunch of keywords that I have set up. So I'm able to find those articles, even if something came up, you know, five, six, seven, eight.
因为我不局限于个人领域。所以我阅读心理学、社会学、经济学和人类学领域的期刊。我阅读得非常、非常贪婪。我也尽量跟踪我遇到的有趣文章。所以在大约过去的15年左右。每次我遇到一篇有趣的文章，我都会保存它。然后我有一个内部的归档系统，允许我用我设置的一堆关键词返回并检索文章。所以我能够找到那些文章，即使是五、六、七、八年前出现的东西。
10 years ago. And it's interesting, Kim, that I have a really terrible memory when it comes to almost everything. I have a very bad memory for faces and names. I forget what I did yesterday. If you asked me what I ate for lunch yesterday, I have absolutely no recollection of it. But for some reason, I have an excellent memory for research studies that were published many years ago. And this has stood us in good stead because I'm often able to see patterns that come up. Just a couple of weeks ago, for example, I was mentioning to a colleague that I've come by the work of a researcher in Chicago, and I've come by his work multiple times in the past, you know, 18 months or so. And once I start to see that, that tells me there's something
10年前。有趣的是，金，我的记忆力在几乎所有事情上都非常糟糕。我对面孔和名字的记忆力很差。我忘记了我昨天做了什么。如果你问我昨天午饭吃了什么，我完全没有记忆。但出于某种原因，我对多年前发表的研究报告有极好的记忆力。这让我们处于有利地位，因为我经常能够看到出现的模式。例如，就在几周前，我向一位同事提到，我遇到了芝加哥一位研究人员的工作，在过去18个月左右的时间里，我多次遇到他的工作。一旦我开始看到这一点，这就告诉我这里正在发生一些
interesting happening here. This person is publishing is really prolific in this area. Let me pay attention to it. I start thinking about ways in which that work can become a hidden brain episode. As you say, you know, multiple times, listeners often reach out to us with interesting questions or stories. Team members come up with things that are happening in the zeitgeist. You know, someone's watching the Johnny Depp, the Amber Heard trial, and we're asking ourselves, is there a story that we can do at Hidden Brain that speaks to those issues? A lot of it is, in some ways, allowing these different strands and ideas to come to us, questions, ideas from the academy, ideas from the published literature, ideas from listeners,
有趣的事情。这个人发表的作品在这个领域非常多产。让我关注它。我开始思考如何让这项工作成为《隐藏的大脑》的一期节目。正如您所说，听众经常带着有趣的问题或故事联系我们。团队成员会提出时下正在发生的事情。你知道，有人在看约翰尼·德普和安珀·赫德的审判，我们问自己，我们能在《隐藏的大脑》中做一个讲述这些问题的故事吗？在某种程度上，很多都是让这些不同的线索和想法来到我们身边，来自学术界的问题、想法，来自已发表文献的想法，来自听众的想法，
ideas from our own team members about what's happening in the news. And the art, I think, is trying to figure out how to sort of mel these together to create Hidden Brain episodes. I wish I could tell you exactly how it was done. I have to say that, in fact, that's probably a hidden brain episode in and of itself, because I feel like people who do things actually are not really expert in telling you how they do the things that they do. Sometimes they think they're experts. If you had Michael Jordan on your podcast or LeBron James or Steph Curry and you ask them, you know, how do you, what do you do on the basketball court? I'm not entirely sure they can actually tell you exactly what they're doing.
来自我们自己团队成员关于新闻中正在发生的事情的想法。我认为艺术在于试图弄清楚如何将这些融合在一起，以创造《隐藏的大脑》节目。我希望我能准确地告诉您它是如何完成的。我必须说，事实上，这本身可能就是一期《隐藏的大脑》节目，因为我觉得做事情的人实际上并不擅长告诉您他们是如何做他们所做的事情的。有时他们认为自己是专家。如果您的播客上有迈克尔·乔丹、勒布朗·詹姆斯或斯蒂芬·库里，您问他们，你知道，您在篮球场上做什么？我不完全确定他们真的能准确地告诉您他们正在做什么。
So part of the ability of doing something involves skills that are, I think, often hidden from the person who's actually doing it. At least those skills are not conscious at a level of saying, here are the specifics five steps that I'm following. All I can tell you is that we are voracious readers and listeners and observers, and we're constantly thinking of ways in which these different strands can produce interesting episodes for our listeners. Well, speaking of interesting episodes, are there any that stand out in your memory? And are they the ones that the listeners love too? Or do you find that some of the stories that you think are terrific weren't as big a hit with your audience? Yeah, this is actually something that I've been meaning to explore as a Hidden Brain episode at some point. Because again, I actually think that that's a really fascinating and interesting question, right? Because you would think that creators would be very good at predicting what it is that their audience is like. And I think in general, that is simply not true.
所以做某事的能力的一部分涉及的技能，我认为，通常对实际做这件事的人来说是隐藏的。至少这些技能在说“这是我遵循的具体五个步骤”的层面上不是有意识的。我能告诉您的只是，我们是贪婪的读者、听众和观察者，我们一直在思考这些不同的线索如何为我们的听众制作有趣的节目。好吧，说到有趣的节目，您的记忆中有没有特别突出的节目？它们也是听众喜欢的吗？还是您发现一些您认为非常棒的故事在您的受众中并不那么受欢迎？是的，这实际上是我一直想在某个时候作为《隐藏的大脑》节目来探索的事情。因为再一次，我实际上认为这是一个非常迷人和有趣的问题，对吧？因为您会认为创作者会非常擅长预测他们的受众喜欢什么。而且我认为总的来说，这根本不是真的。
You know, if it was true, we wouldn't have as many duds as we have in the publishing industry or in the movies, right? The people who are skilled at making things, if they truly understood what audiences want, Why would they go out and make failures? Why would they make movies that land with a thud? And the interesting thing, of course, is that when you're sitting in a theater watching a movie, I don't know if this has happened to you, Kim, but it's happened to be multiple times. I can sit and watch a movie, and I know three minutes into the movie that this movie is not going to work. And I know three minutes into the movie, this movie is a failure.
你知道，如果这是真的，我们在出版业或电影业就不会有那么多失败之作了，对吧？那些擅长制作东西的人，如果他们真的了解受众想要什么，为什么他们还要去制造失败？为什么他们要制作那些反响平平的电影？当然，有趣的是，当您坐在电影院看电影时，我不知道这是否发生在您身上，金，但这发生在我身上多次。我可以坐着看电影，在电影开始三分钟后我就知道这部电影行不通。在电影开始三分钟后我就知道这部电影是失败的。
The characters are not too wooden. The plot doesn't work. It looks, you know, it's a bunch of stereotypes and cliches. And I have to ask myself, then, how is it that I'm able to sit in a theater within three minutes and know something isn't going to work? And there's been a whole team of people who've worked on this movie for like five years and they've spent $20 million doing it. Why couldn't they see the same thing? And in some ways, I think the question answers itself, which is that I think when you're very close to something, you genuinely lose the ability to see what actually is working and not working. And this is why someone who is an amateur can come into something and say, well, why don't we do it?
角色太木讷了。情节行不通。它看起来，你知道，是一堆刻板印象和陈词滥调。我不得不问自己，那么，我是怎么做到坐在电影院里三分钟内就知道某件事行不通的？有一整队人已经为这部电影工作了五年，他们花了2000万美元。为什么他们看不到同样的事情？在某种程度上，我认为问题本身就有了答案，那就是我认为当你离某件事非常近时，你确实失去了看到什么真正有效、什么无效的能力。这就是为什么业余爱好者可以进入某件事并说，好吧，为什么我们不这样做呢？
it this way. This would make much more sense. And all the professionals say, well, of course we can't do it that way. That wouldn't work at all. But I think amateurs are often able to see things because they're able to see with fresh eyes. You know, sometimes this is called the curse of knowledge, of course, which is that the more knowledge you have, the harder it becomes for you to actually see which end is up because you're so flooded with information and ideas and thoughts that you you sort of lose the ability to see something as a novice. So the short answer to your question is, you know, I think quite regularly people have surprised us in terms of the episodes that they have liked compared to the episodes that we have liked. But in general, I will say that when I think
这样做会更有意义。所有的专业人士都说，好吧，当然我们不能那样做。那根本行不通。但我认为业余爱好者通常能够看到事物，因为他们能够用新鲜的眼光去看待。你知道，有时这被称为“知识的诅咒”，当然，即你拥有的知识越多，你就越难真正看到哪一端是向上的，因为你被信息、想法和思想淹没了，以至于你失去了作为新手看待事物的能力。所以对您问题的简短回答是，你知道，我认为人们经常在他们喜欢的节目与我们喜欢的节目方面给我们带来惊喜。但总的来说，我会说，当我思考
about the episodes, my favorite hidden brain episodes, the answer to that question is always very simple. You know, when people ask me, what's my favorite hidden brain episode, I always tell them that my favorite episode is the one that we're doing next week. Of course. And I only mean that partly facetiously, I actually think that that's actually genuinely true. I'm someone personally who sort of lives almost entirely in the future. So the future is more clear to me than the present and the past. And I'm always invariably excited by what we have coming down the pike. So invariably, I'm more excited by those episodes and the episodes we've published already.
关于节目，我最喜欢的《隐藏的大脑》节目，那个问题的答案总是非常简单。你知道，当人们问我，我最喜欢的《隐藏的大脑》节目是什么时，我总是告诉他们，我最喜欢的节目是我们下周要做的那个。当然。我只是半开玩笑地这么说，我实际上认为这确实是真的。我个人是一个几乎完全生活在未来的人。所以未来对我来说比现在和过去更清晰。我总是对我们即将推出的东西感到兴奋。所以总是，我对那些节目比我们已经发布的节目更兴奋。
Can you give us a hint as to what you're working on now? When I was talking with your executive producer a couple of weeks ago, Tara Boyle, she mentioned a piece that you're working on having to do with some dreams that a man had years ago, that one of which came true and one of which he is afraid will come true. Yeah, I won't get into all of the details because I want listeners to listen to this episode. This is an episode that, in fact, we've been working on for, I would say, almost two years at this point. And that's the other interesting thing about Hidden Brain episodes, which is some of them come together in three weeks and some of them take months or even years to put together. But this is a really unusual story about a man who had two dreams. And of course, the dreams were just strange dreams like all dreams are. And he dismissed them, except that one of the dreams purported to tell him how long he was going to live.
您能给我们一点暗示，您现在正在做什么吗？几周前我和您的执行制片人塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）交谈时，她提到了您正在制作的一篇关于一个男人多年前做的一些梦的作品，其中一个梦成真了，而另一个他担心会成真。是的，我不会深入所有细节，因为我希望听众去收听这一期节目。事实上，这是一期我们已经制作了，我想说，此时此刻已经快两年了的节目。这也是《隐藏的大脑》节目的另一个有趣之处，即有些节目在三周内就完成了，有些则需要几个月甚至几年才能完成。但这是一个关于一个做了两个梦的男人的非常不寻常的故事。当然，梦就像所有的梦一样，只是奇怪的梦。他忽略了它们，除了其中一个梦声称告诉他他能活多久。
And he had these dreams when he was a teenager. And then he put the dreams out of his mind. And then what happened is some years later, the first dream that he'd had that night, which was also a bizarre dream, came true in almost every way, shape, and form. And it made him start to ask himself, is it possible that I was told something that night about my future? And is it possible that the second dream, which purported to tell me how long I was going to live, is also going to come true.
他在十几岁时做了这些梦。然后他把这些梦抛在了脑后。然后发生的事情是几年后，他那天晚上做的第一个梦，那也是一个离奇的梦，在每一个方面、形状和形式上都成真了。这让他开始问自己，那天晚上我是否被告知了一些关于我未来的事情？第二个梦，声称告诉我我能活多久，是否也有可能成真。
And he reached out to Hidden Brain shortly before the birthday where his dream had forecast that he was going to die, asking us how to think about these dreams. And of course, it's a fascinating story from a psychological point of view because it raises really interesting questions about how we think about our own mortality, how we think about predictions, how we think about prognostications, you know, how we think about patterns in terms of the things that occurred to us. The brain is a pattern recognition machine as many listeners of your show, I'm sure, are aware of. But how does this affect us in terms of our daily behavior? Do we share these fears with other people, do we keep them to ourselves? So I feel like this is an episode that
他在他梦中预测他会去世的生日之前不久联系了《隐藏的大脑》，询问我们如何看待这些梦。当然，从心理学的角度来看，这是一个迷人的故事，因为它提出了关于我们如何看待自己的死亡、我们如何看待预测、我们如何看待预兆、你知道，我们如何看待发生在我们身上的事情的模式的非常有趣的问题。大脑是一台模式识别机器，正如您节目的许多听众肯定知道的那样。但这在日常行为方面如何影响我们？我们与其他人分享这些恐惧吗，还是我们把它们留给自己？所以我感觉这是一期
explore so many interesting themes of human behavior because it has so many different ramifications of how we think about ourselves and our lives. And it's an episode that I've, you know, I really love this episode and I can't wait for it to come out in a few weeks. I'm looking forward to it as well. So let's just switch gears for a minute and talk about your most recent book, which is called Useful Delusions, the Power and Paradox of the Self-Deceiving brain. I would wager that most people at first blush would say self-delusion is a bad thing. What kinds of delusions are you talking about when you talk about useful delusions? Yeah, so I think you're going to pick up a pattern here, Kim. One of the things that I interest me is when I find paradoxes in my
探索了如此多有趣的人类行为主题的节目，因为它对我们如何看待自己和我们的生活有如此多不同的影响。这是一期我，你知道，我真的很喜欢这期节目，我迫不及待地想让它在几周后发布。我也很期待。那么让我们换个话题，谈谈您最近的书，书名叫《有用的错觉：自欺大脑的力量与悖论》。我敢打赌，大多数人乍一看会说自欺是一种坏事。当您谈论有用的错觉时，您指的是什么样的错觉？是的，所以我认为您会在这里发现一个模式，金。我感兴趣的事情之一是，当我发现我自己的行为中存在悖论时，
own behavior, I often follow them because I say this is interesting. And so one of the interesting pieces of research that I've come by in the last, I would say, five, ten years is ideas that sometimes behaving rationally doesn't produce the outcomes that you think it's going to produce. And I feel like I run into this all the time in my own life because I'm a very, very rational person. And I find myself befuddled and bewildered when rationality doesn't produce the outcomes that you expect. So, you know, let me give you the simplest of examples.
我经常跟随它们，因为我说这很有趣。所以我过去五、十年里遇到的有趣的研究之一是，有时表现得理性并不能产生您认为会产生的后果。我觉得我在自己的生活中一直遇到这种情况，因为我是一个非常、非常理性的人。当我发现理性不能产生您预期的结果时，我感到困惑和不知所措。所以，你知道，让我给您举一个最简单的例子。
The controversy we've had in the United States about the efficacy of vaccinations against COVID-19. To my mind, it seems so self-evidently, blindingly obvious that if vaccines have been developed that are safe and effective and you have a deadly virus that's raging, a virus that can kill you, of course people are going to want to take those vaccinations. You know, it's like you're drowning and someone's throwing you a, you know, a line, a life raft. And of course, you're going to grab it, you know, because you would want to save yourself. And of course, what we've seen in the last 18 months of the pandemic unfolding is that people, in fact, are not behaving rationally. And for rationalists such as myself, this has often been, you know,
我们在美国关于COVID-19疫苗有效性的争议。在我看来，如果已经开发出安全有效的疫苗，而您有一种肆虐的致命病毒，一种可以杀死您的病毒，那么人们当然会想要接种这些疫苗，这似乎是显而易见的、盲目明显的。你知道，这就像您快淹死了，有人给您扔了一根绳子，一个救生筏。当然，您会抓住它，你知道，因为您想拯救自己。当然，我们在过去18个月大流行展开中所看到的是，人们实际上并没有表现得理性。对于像我这样的理性主义者来说，这通常是，你知道，
deeply dispiriting and befuddling and bewildering. And so I've increasingly been drawn to research that purports to ask the question, well, why is that? Why is it that people, in fact, do not follow what is the most rational course of action? What, you know, is it possible that, you know, so one explanation is that people don't follow the most rational course of action just because they're silly or they're foolish or they're misguided. And that's possible. But of course, our minds are, you know, that have been constructed over billions of years of evolution, they're very, very skilled at doing certain things. And the brains that we have handed down to us from evolution are in fact very skilled at solving problems of survival. You would think that if there's one thing the brain is really, really good at doing, given that, you know, we've been produced by a process of natural selection.
非常令人沮丧、困惑和不知所措。所以我越来越被那些旨在提出这样一个问题的研究所吸引，好吧，为什么会这样？为什么人们实际上不遵循最理性的行动方针？什么，你知道，是否有可能，你知道，所以一种解释是，人们不遵循最理性的行动方针只是因为他们愚蠢或愚昧或被误导了。这有可能。但当然，我们的思维是，你知道，经过数十亿年的进化构建的，它们在做某些事情方面非常、非常熟练。我们从进化中传下来的大脑实际上非常擅长解决生存问题。您会认为，如果大脑有一件事是非常、非常擅长的，考虑到，你知道，我们是由自然选择的过程产生的。
The one thing the brain should be really good at doing is surviving, because, of course, all of us come from a long line of survivors. The fact that you and I exist today is because our ancestors learned to survive. They had brains that allowed them to survive. And so when you look at the brain, it's in some ways facile to basically say there's something wrong with the brain that causes us not to be able to survive because you would think the one thing, again, natural selection would design into the brain is a deep capacity for survival. And so when I think about this, I start to ask myself, well, then what are the mechanisms
大脑应该非常擅长做的一件事就是生存，因为，当然，我们所有人都来自长期的幸存者。您和我今天存在的事实是因为我们的祖先学会了生存。他们拥有让他们生存的大脑。所以当您看大脑时，说大脑有什么问题导致我们无法生存，在某种程度上是肤浅的，因为您会认为，再一次，自然选择会设计进大脑的一件事是对生存的深刻能力。所以当我思考这个问题时，我开始问自己，好吧，那么大脑中有什么机制
in the brain that prompt us towards non-rational? or irrationality, and is it possible, at least in our evolutionary history, that these brain mechanisms played a useful role? Is it possible that they actually served us in some kind of useful way in our prior past, in our prior history? And even though it might not be functional today, that might explain then why it is we have those algorithms of the brain today. So the simplest example to give would be, you know, at multiple points in human history, but also in the history of other species from whom we are descended, you know, animals faced huge survival problems when it came to famine, when it came to, you know, acquiring enough calories to stay alive. And so unsurprisingly,
促使我们走向非理性？或者非理性，并且有可能，至少在我们的进化史上，这些大脑机制发挥了有用的作用吗？它们是否有可能在我们的过去、在我们的过去历史中以某种有用的方式服务于我们？即使它今天可能不起作用，那可能就能解释为什么我们今天拥有这些大脑算法。所以最简单的例子是，你知道，在人类历史的多个点上，以及在我们所继承的其他物种的历史中，你知道，动物在饥荒时，在你知道，获取足够的卡路里以保持生命时，面临巨大的生存问题。所以不出所料，
our brains are designed to pay very, very close attention to any caloric restrictions that we have because in our ancestral past, famine was a way that we often died. And so, So even though today many of us live in a sea of plenty when it comes to calories and we're surrounded by junk food and soda and potato chips and all of those things, our brains still carry the imprint of what our ancestral brains had, which is a deep fear of famine, a deep fear of not having enough calories to live on. And so our brains in some ways are designed to make us eat even though we might not actually need to eat, even though, in fact, eating might not serve us well.
我们的大脑被设计为非常、非常密切地关注我们拥有的任何卡路里限制，因为在我们的祖先过去，饥荒是我们经常死亡的一种方式。所以，即使今天我们许多人生活在卡路里的海洋中，我们被垃圾食品、苏打水、薯片和所有这些东西包围着，我们的大脑仍然带有我们祖先大脑的印记，即对饥荒的深刻恐惧，对没有足够的卡路里维持生命的深刻恐惧。所以我们的大脑在某种程度上被设计为让我们吃，即使我们可能实际上不需要吃，即使，事实上，吃可能对我们没有好处。
And so it's an example of how we might have ancient algorithms in our mind that served our ancestors very well. But because the human world in which we live in has changed so dramatically right now, the ancestral algorithms no longer work. And in fact, might not only no longer work, they might actually be counterproductive. When you think about the epidemics we have around hypertension or strokes and heart disease, some of that has to do with our lifestyle choices in terms of eating and exercise. And that's driven in some ways by these algorithms in the brain. So similarly, when you think about the ways in which our minds operate, there are many, many domains in which, in fact, our minds are designed to have delusions, and you could argue that some of those delusions might in fact be useful. They're actually productive today. And I think the simplest and clearest example of this is in the realm of parenting and parenthood. Because when I know when my own daughter was born many years ago, the day she was born, I was sort of the most special day of my own life. But what I was, When she was born, I had a firm conviction that not only was she the most special child in the world, I had the sense that she was the most special child in the history of the world,
所以这是一个例子，说明我们思维中可能存在古老的算法，这些算法很好地服务于我们的祖先。但因为我们生活的人类世界现在发生了如此巨大的变化，祖先算法不再起作用了。事实上，不仅可能不再起作用，它们实际上可能适得其反。当您想到我们周围的高血压或中风和心脏病流行时，其中一些与我们在饮食和锻炼方面的生活方式选择有关。这在某种程度上是由大脑中的这些算法驱动的。同样，当您想到我们思维运作的方式时，有很多、很多领域，事实上，我们的思维被设计为拥有错觉，您可以争辩说其中一些错觉实际上可能是有用的。它们今天实际上是富有成效的。我认为最简单、最清晰的例子是在育儿和为人父母的领域。因为我知道当我的女儿多年前出生时，她出生的那天，我感觉那是我一生中最特别的一天。但当她出生时，我有一种坚定的信念，不仅她是世界上最特别的孩子，我有一种感觉，她是世界历史上最特别的孩子，
that she was the most wonderful and important thing that had ever happened in the history of the universe. Now, clearly, when I thought about that rationally, that has to be a delusion. That cannot possibly be true that my one daughter, when she was born, she was the most special thing that happened in the history of the universe. And, of course, when you look around and you find that other parents have exactly the same delusions about their own children, you start to say, okay, this has to be a delusion. It can't possibly be the case that all these children are the most special thing that happen in the
她是宇宙历史上发生过的最美妙、最重要的事情。现在，显然，当我理性地思考时，那一定是一个错觉。我的一个女儿，当她出生时，她是宇宙历史上发生过的最特别的事情，这不可能成真。当然，当您环顾四周，发现其他父母对他们自己的孩子也有完全相同的错觉时，您开始说，好吧，这一定是一个错觉。所有这些孩子都是历史上发生过的最特别的事情，这不可能成真。
history of the world. And then you ask yourself, well, why is it that we have this delusion? And the answer is, as I have discovered through 16 years of parenting, parenting is really, really difficult. It's expensive, it's time-consuming, it's stressful, it's challenging. For our ancestors, it often involved incredible risks that often put their own lives at risk to make sure that their offspring survived. And the delusion that we have that our children are extraordinary and special is in fact a very useful delusion to have because it allows us to commit the time and the resources and the effort
历史的世界。然后您问自己，好吧，为什么我们会有这种错觉？答案是，正如我通过16年的育儿所发现的那样，育儿真的、真的很难。它昂贵、耗时、压力大、充满挑战。对于我们的祖先来说，它通常涉及令人难以置信的风险，这些风险经常使他们自己的生命处于危险之中，以确保他们的后代生存。我们认为我们的孩子是非凡和特别的错觉，事实上是一个非常有用的错觉，因为它允许我们投入时间和资源以及努力
that are needed to successfully raise children to adulthood. Now, can parents go too far with this? Can you basically believe in the extraordinaryness of your children to the point where you actually are encouraging them to do things that are harmful or malevolent? You know, there are examples of that where children do terrible things and their parents stand by them because they can't bear to think that their children are bad people. But in general, this is a very useful delusion to have because, of course, if we didn't have this delusion, many of us, we thought very rationally in a cost-benefit way, you know, do I really want to invest this much time and effort in the care of somebody else? Many of us might rationally conclude that we don't wish to do those things. And, of course, that would not be good for the survival of the species and for the continuation.
成功抚养孩子长大成人所必需的。现在，父母在这方面会走得太远吗？您基本上可以相信您孩子的不凡，以至于您实际上是在鼓励他们做有害或恶毒的事情吗？你知道，有这样的例子，孩子做了可怕的事情，而他们的父母支持他们，因为他们无法忍受认为他们的孩子是坏人。但总的来说，这是一个非常有用的错觉，因为，当然，如果我们没有这种错觉，我们许多人，如果我们以成本效益的方式非常理性地思考，你知道，我真的想在照顾别人的事情上投入这么多时间和精力吗？我们许多人可能会理性地得出结论，我们不希望做这些事情。当然，这对物种的生存和延续是不利的。
of our genes. And so that would be a simple example of a useful delusion at work, but it turns out that's one of many kinds of delusions that, in fact, might be irrational or non-rational, but in fact might have a profoundly salutary role for us and our species. I am sure your daughter is the most extraordinary person on the planet. You're exactly right. I'm often amazed by the way that you get scientists to tell their personal stories and weave together their work and their lives. How do you get them to open up and reflect in this way and a challenge I think we both share, which is to get them to speak in plain English? Yeah, so it is the case that I
我们的基因。所以这将是一个有用的错觉在起作用的简单例子，但事实证明，这是许多种错觉之一，事实上，它们可能是非理性的或非理性的，但事实上可能对我们和我们的物种具有深刻的有益作用。我相信您的女儿是这个星球上最非凡的人。您说得完全正确。我经常对您让科学家讲述他们的个人故事并将他们的工作和生活交织在一起的方式感到惊讶。您是如何让他们敞开心扉并以这种方式反思的？我认为我们两人都有一个共同的挑战，那就是让他们用简单的英语说话？是的，所以确实是这样，我
think we talked about this actually a little while earlier, which is I think when you spend a lot of time learning something and studying something, you're so attuned to the small nuances of what you're studying, you know, the details of what you're studying, that sometimes it becomes hard, I think, for you to see your own work as a novice would, as an amateur would. So, for example, I'm often amazed that the researchers and scientists that I speak with do not have a good understanding of what it is about their work that actually would interest the general public. What is it about your work that actually would speak to the general public? I think many researchers genuinely find it hard to actually answer that question. And they find it hard
我想我们之前其实讨论过这一点，那就是当你花大量时间学习和研究某样东西时，你会对所研究事物的细微差别非常敏感，也就是你所研究事物的细节，以至于有时我认为你很难以新手或业余爱好者的视角来看待自己的工作。例如，我经常感到惊讶的是，我交谈过的研究人员和科学家并不清楚他们的工作究竟有哪些方面会引起公众的兴趣。你的工作中究竟有什么能引起公众的共鸣？我认为许多研究人员确实很难回答这个问题。他们觉得很难，
precisely because they know so much, precisely because, in fact, they are so smart. so knowledgeable. This is, in fact, the curse of knowledge at work, that if you're used to, you know, talking to other people who are fellow academics, who are also deeply immersed and enmeshed in the field in which you're working, it's difficult to step out of that and speak in a way that is accessible or comprehensible to a general audience. So that, you know, in many ways, I think of Hidden Brain as being a bridge between the academy and the public square. I sort of think about the work that we're doing as a service role, that we're trying to translate important and interesting ideas from the academy and make them accessible and relevant to people's lives,
恰恰是因为他们知道得太多，恰恰是因为他们实际上太聪明、知识太渊博了。这实际上就是“知识的诅咒”在起作用。如果你习惯于与同行交流，与那些同样深陷于你所研究领域的人交流，那么很难跳出这个圈子，用一种普通受众能够理解或接受的方式进行表达。所以，在很多方面，我认为《Hidden Brain》是学术界与公共领域之间的一座桥梁。我把我们所做的工作视为一种服务角色，我们试图将学术界重要且有趣的思想进行转化，使其变得易于理解并与人们的生活息息相关，
to the lives of people who are outside of the academy. And I think this work is really important to do because, of course, you know, it's not just the creation of knowledge that is vital in our world. It's the dissemination of knowledge that is vital. And the public plays a really important role in maintaining and supporting science, right? So taxpayer dollars go to fund universities, they go to fund research institutions. It's really important for ordinary people to feel. Science is not just some, you know, abstruse thing that's happening in some ivory tower. The work that's been done in the academy actually has relevance to my life. It actually can make my own life better. And so there's a really important, I think, function in playing this bridge
与学术界之外人们的生活息息相关。我认为这项工作非常重要，因为当然，在这个世界上，不仅知识的创造至关重要，知识的传播也同样重要。公众在维护和支持科学方面发挥着非常重要的作用，对吧？纳税人的钱资助了大学，资助了研究机构。让普通人感受到这一点非常重要。科学不仅仅是发生在象牙塔里的一些深奥的东西。学术界所做的工作实际上与我的生活息息相关。它实际上可以让我的生活变得更好。因此，我认为在学术界和公共领域之间扮演这座桥梁的角色，具有非常重要的功能。
role between the academy and the public square. Now, how do you get scientists to talk? How do you get them to focus on stuff that is of relevance to the general public? I think some of this comes down to the trust that I think Hidden Brain has earned within the academy. We are seen as being a serious show. We're seen as a show that deeply cares about science and takes scientists very seriously. I think I genuinely have a deep affection and a regard for the science and the scientists that we profile on Hidden Brain. I am someone who reads academic publications for pleasure. I can think of spending time on a weekend reading academic papers.
那么，你如何让科学家们开口说话？你如何让他们关注与公众相关的事情？我认为这在一定程度上归功于《Hidden Brain》在学术界赢得的信任。我们被视为一个严肃的节目。我们被视为一个深切关心科学并非常重视科学家的节目。我认为我对《Hidden Brain》中介绍的科学和科学家确实怀有深厚的感情和敬意。我是一个为了乐趣而阅读学术出版物的人。我甚至可以在周末花时间阅读学术论文。
and I think of this as being just as enjoyable as watching Netflix. So I think when I speak with scientists or when we reach out to scientists, they know they're speaking with an interlocutor who genuinely understands and gets them and actually wants is sort of enthusiastic about the worlds in which they operate. So I think scientists have come to trust us in some ways in being able to tell their stories in a way that actually reaches people well. But it is the case that putting together a Hidden Brain episode and putting together an interview with a scientist,
我认为这和看Netflix一样令人愉快。所以，当我和科学家交谈或我们联系科学家时，他们知道他们是在与一位真正理解他们、欣赏他们，并且对他们所处的领域充满热情的对话者交流。因此，我认为科学家们在某种程度上已经开始信任我们，相信我们能够以一种真正触达人们的方式讲述他们的故事。但制作一期《Hidden Brain》节目，并准备对科学家的采访，
often involves extraordinary amounts of background preparation and work. And, you know, many of my team members play a very active role in thinking through very carefully, you know, what is the arc of this person's research? How can we best profile it so that it lands in the best possible light so the ideas become the most accessible? How do we connect this with people's lives in a way that makes people feel like these ideas speak to me?
往往涉及大量的背景准备和工作。而且，我的许多团队成员在仔细思考方面发挥了非常积极的作用，比如：这个人的研究脉络是什么？我们如何才能最好地展示它，使其以最佳方式呈现，从而让这些思想变得最易于理解？我们如何将它与人们的生活联系起来，让人们觉得这些思想与我有关？
One research study that has really spoken to me was conducted some time ago by researcher, I believe, at Columbia University, Chardin Lin Sigler. You know, she was talking with, she was presenting research to students about science. And she told, you know, in this research experiment, some students were told about Albert Einstein and were told, you know, Einstein was one of the smartest people who ever lived. His ideas were so brilliant, even though he was working a century ago. his ideas was so smart that we're still struggling to understand his ideas today, that very, very few people truly understand Albert Einstein's insights. So that's one group of people. And there's another group of people who are told, you know, about the missteps and foibles and mistakes that Einstein made, the times in his life, for example, when he couldn't solve a problem,
有一项研究确实引起了我的共鸣，那是前段时间由哥伦比亚大学的研究员Chardin Lin Sigler进行的。她当时正在向学生介绍科学研究。在这次实验中，一些学生被告知阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦的事迹，他们被告知爱因斯坦是有史以来最聪明的人之一。尽管他是一个世纪前的人，但他的思想非常卓越，以至于我们今天仍在努力理解他的思想，真正理解阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦见解的人寥寥无几。这是一组人。还有另一组人被告知爱因斯坦所犯的失误、弱点和错误，例如他生命中无法解决某个问题的时刻，
when he found that he didn't have the mathematical skills to solve a particular challenge, He had to turn to other people for help in order to be able to solve those challenges. And then what shot on Lindsigler did was a very simple question. She basically said, if you tell these two versions of the stories of Einstein to students, who ends up being more engaged in science? Who ends up thinking that science is for them? And perhaps the way I'm presenting this makes the answer obvious. But when you present Einstein as a genius beyond all geniuses,
当他发现自己没有数学技能来解决某个特定挑战时，他不得不向其他人寻求帮助才能解决这些挑战。然后，Chardin Lin Sigler提出了一个非常简单的问题。她基本上是说，如果你向学生讲述这两个版本的爱因斯坦故事，谁会更投入到科学中？谁会认为科学适合他们？也许我这样呈现方式让答案显而易见。但是，当你把爱因斯坦呈现为超越所有天才的天才时，
whose ideas are incomprehensible to us even 100 years later, many students are perfectly happy to say, okay, Albert Einstein was a super smart guy, but they don't think that they can become the next Albert Einstein because they say, I'm still having trouble with my algebra class. You know, I still, I'm having trouble with trigonometry. How can I possibly, you know, aspire to be Albert Einstein? On the other hand, when you sort of describe the limitations and challenges that Albert Einstein had, you know, he becomes much more relatable as a character.
即使在100年后，他的思想对我们来说仍然是不可理解的，许多学生很乐意说，好吧，阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦是个超级聪明的人，但他们不认为自己能成为下一个阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦，因为他们说，我还在为代数课发愁。你知道，我还在为三角学发愁。我怎么可能渴望成为阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦呢？另一方面，当你描述阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦所面临的局限和挑战时，他作为一个人物变得更加亲切了。
And now you sort of say, well, I can relate to who this person is. And yes, some of his ideas are really difficult to understand, but like me, he struggled, and like me, he had setbacks, and like me, he had failures. And I feel like this is a really important insight in science communication that I think many scientists forget, which is it's important not just to tell people about the insight you have when you've reached the top of the mountain. It's really important to communicate to people the struggle it takes to get to the top of the mountain, because it's the struggle to get to the top of the mountain that, in
现在你会说，嗯，我可以理解这个人是谁。是的，他的一些思想确实很难理解，但像我一样，他挣扎过，像我一样，他经历过挫折，像我一样，他经历过失败。我觉得这是科学传播中一个非常重要的见解，我认为许多科学家忘记了这一点，那就是：不仅要告诉人们当你到达山顶时所拥有的见解，更重要的是要向人们传达到达山顶所经历的挣扎，因为正是到达山顶的挣扎，
fact is where everybody else is who's listening to that episode. Everybody else who says, I have an insight, but I don't quite know if it's a scientific insight. I don't know how to actually take the steps to turn this insight into a rigorous scientific conclusion. They want to hear about the struggle involved in getting to the mountaintop. And when you think about every good science movie that you've seen, you know, think about movies about great scientists, what you'll find, of course, is exactly the same pattern. The movie doesn't start with the moment of blinding scientific insight, and the rest of the movie is just as this hagiographic look
实际上是所有正在收听该节目的人所处的位置。其他所有说“我有一个见解，但我不知道它是否是一个科学见解”的人。我不知道如何真正采取步骤将这个见解转化为严谨的科学结论。他们想听到关于到达山顶过程中的挣扎。当你想到你看过的每一部优秀的科学电影时，想想关于伟大科学家的电影，你会发现，当然，模式完全一样。电影不是从闪现科学灵感的时刻开始的，剩下的电影也不是那种对某人卓越思想的圣徒传式的审视，
at sort of someone's brilliant ideas, it always starts with the story of what were the challenges you faced, what were the setbacks you face, what is the story that allows you to basically see, I can understand that this insight was hard won. This insight was involved significant challenge. It involved a journey. I mean, think of any adventure story that you've watched or read or liked.
它总是从你面临的挑战、你面临的挫折的故事开始，这个故事让你基本上能看出，我可以理解这种见解是来之不易的。这种见解涉及重大的挑战。它涉及一段旅程。我的意思是，想想你观看、阅读或喜欢的任何冒险故事。
You know, you don't start the movie by basically saying, the end has been reached, the victory has been accomplished. The movie always has to start with laying out what the challenges are. And what you're doing with laying out the challenges is really engaging people in the problem, not just engaging people in the solution. I think this is a really important insight that a lot of people in science communication forget. The central challenge is not engaging people in the solution. The central challenge is engaging people in the problem. Because once you've engaged people in the problem, and then you give them the solution.
你知道，你不会通过基本上说“终点已经到达，胜利已经取得”来开始电影。电影总是必须从陈述挑战是什么开始。而你通过陈述挑战所做的事情，实际上是让人们参与到问题中，而不仅仅是让人们参与到解决方案中。我认为这是一个非常重要的见解，许多从事科学传播的人都忘记了。核心挑战不是让人们参与解决方案。核心挑战是让人们参与问题。因为一旦你让人们参与了问题，然后你再给他们解决方案，
They're receptive to the solution. They basically say, aha, I understand now why this solution is relevant to my life, because you've actually taken the time to connect them, connect their lives, their problems with the problem of discovery itself. So you have a really unique view as someone outside the field who is very knowledgeable about behavioral science research, and you've explained your attraction to it. You've been paying attention to it for years and years.
他们就会接受这个解决方案。他们基本上会说，啊哈，我现在明白了为什么这个解决方案与我的生活相关，因为你实际上花时间将他们联系起来，将他们的生活、他们的问题与发现本身的问题联系起来。所以，作为一个领域外的人，你对行为科学研究非常了解，并且你已经解释了你对它的吸引力。你多年来一直关注它。
So given that and given all of the string that you save over time looking for patterns, can you talk about what you think are the big topics and trends that we might be seeing in the near or the distant future? Yeah, I have to confess I'm probably not very good at predicting the future. In some ways, there's a robust psychological science that basically says very few people are good at predicting the future. So if you were to ask me, you know, where are these fields going to go in five years' time or ten? years time, I have to confess, I don't know the answers to those questions. I don't quite know who to tell me what are the, what are going to be the hot areas in psychology five years from now, ten years from now. I think I've learned enough to know that I am not going to be
那么考虑到这一点，以及你随着时间推移寻找模式所积累的所有经验，你能谈谈你认为我们在不久的将来或遥远的未来可能会看到的重大主题和趋势吗？是的，我必须承认我可能不太擅长预测未来。在某种程度上，有一种稳健的心理科学基本上说很少有人擅长预测未来。所以如果你问我，这些领域在五年或十年后会走向何方，我必须承认，我不知道这些问题的答案。我不太知道该找谁来告诉我五年后、十年后心理学的热门领域是什么。我想我已经学到了足够多的东西，知道我不会
very good at predicting what those things are. In some ways, I have, let's say, a more modest approach to sort of thinking about my work, and that is to basically pay attention to a lot of different things that are happening and asking myself what's interesting. about these lots of different things that are happening. And some of those things are more modest. They're not sort of sweeping changes that would transform an entire field. But it's an interesting body of research that basically says, let's look at sort of this interesting idea and sort of see where we can go from here. So I think there's, you know, I have lots of interesting, you know, interests and lots of different things. But if you were to ask me big questions, you know,
非常擅长预测那些事情。在某种程度上，我对思考我的工作有一种更谦逊的方法，那就是基本上关注正在发生的许多不同事情，并问自己这些正在发生的许多不同事情中有什么是有趣的。其中一些事情比较温和。它们不是那种会改变整个领域的彻底变革。但这是一个有趣的研究主体，它基本上说，让我们看看这个有趣的想法，看看我们能从这里走向何方。所以我认为，我有许多有趣的兴趣和许多不同的事情。但如果你问我大问题，
how is economics going to be transformed in the next 10 years, you know, is how is social psychology going to be transformed in the next 15 years? I have to confess, I am probably, not the right person to ask him. Okay, well, let me throw this at you to sort of close things out here today. Given that we live in what I believe is a fairly anti-science, anti-intellectual society right now, how do you account for the popularity of a show like Hidden Brain? Yeah, that's a good question. And I have to say that if I was being perfectly candid, I have to say,
经济学在未来10年将如何转型，社会心理学在未来15年将如何转型？我必须承认，我可能不是合适的人选。好吧，让我抛出这个问题来结束今天的讨论。鉴于我们现在生活在一个我认为相当反科学、反智的社会中，你如何解释像《Hidden Brain》这样的节目的受欢迎程度？是的，这是一个好问题。我必须说，如果我完全坦诚的话，我必须说，
I would have to say that I'm somewhat surprised as you seem to be. Because I do think that what we're doing in many ways is sort of very serious and it's a very sober show. We're focused on complex ideas and we're trying to sort of present complex ideas before people. And like you, I think, you know, maybe 10 years ago, if you'd asked me how successful would a show like this be, I would say it would be modestly successful because the audience for complexity and nuance is not very big. And I have to say that I've been surprised, pleasantly surprised, at how popular a show like Hidden Brain is. I think there are some things that we're doing that, in fact, are helpful, which is that we are constantly trying to connect the world of science with the world of storytelling and trying to make stories as accessible and as interesting as possible. I think we're genuinely interested and curious about the worlds in which we're covering.
我不得不说，我和你一样感到有些惊讶。因为我确实认为我们所做的事情在很多方面是非常严肃的，这是一个非常冷静的节目。我们专注于复杂的思想，我们试图在人们面前呈现复杂的思想。和你一样，我想，如果10年前你问我这样的节目会多么成功，我会说它会适度成功，因为对复杂性和细微差别的受众并不多。我必须说，我对《Hidden Brain》这样的节目如此受欢迎感到惊讶，感到惊喜。我认为我们正在做的一些事情确实是有帮助的，那就是我们不断尝试将科学世界与讲故事的世界联系起来，并试图让故事尽可能易于理解和有趣。我认为我们对我们所报道的世界确实感兴趣并充满好奇。
And I think that enthusiasm comes through in the work that we're doing. I hope it comes through in just the conversation we're having right now. I hope people are hearing my own enthusiasm and passion for the fields that we cover. But also, I think podcasting in general has turned out to be this extraordinary gift because podcasting, of course, is fundamentally a business of niches. It's basically, are you, are there enough people in this niche who are fascinated by what you're doing that they're willing to actually listen to you? And it turns out there, in fact, is a sizable number of people who are interested in thoughtful
我认为这种热情体现在我们所做的工作中。我希望它体现在我们现在的对话中。我希望人们能听到我对我们所报道领域的自己的热情和激情。但我也认为，播客总体上已经成为一份非凡的礼物，因为播客当然从根本上说是利基市场。它基本上是，在这个利基市场中是否有足够多的人对你所做的事情着迷，以至于他们愿意真正听你讲？事实证明，确实有相当多的人对深思熟虑的
conversations, who are interested in nuance, who are interested in what their own minds are doing, who are interested in how they can modify and change how their thinking and how they should be responding to the world to have better relationships or perform better or function better at work or in their lives. That audience turns out not to be trivial. It turns out to be substantial. So, you know, I would say the short answer to your question, Kim, is that that you know, the short answer really to how anyone gets successful, which is they work very hard and most of it is luck.
对话感兴趣，对细微差别感兴趣，对他们自己的思想在做什么感兴趣，对他们如何修改和改变他们的思维方式以及他们应该如何应对世界以拥有更好的人际关系、表现更好或在工作或生活中发挥更好感兴趣。事实证明，这些受众并不微不足道。事实证明，他们是相当可观的。所以，我会说回答你问题的简短答案是，Kim，你知道，关于任何人如何获得成功的简短答案确实是，他们工作非常努力，而且大部分是运气。
Well, Shankar Vedantam, thank you so much for speaking with me today. This has been a great pleasure. Very happy to have some time with you. Thank you, Kim. I'm a huge fan of everything that psychologists and the APA does, and I'm hugely grateful to the many scientists and researchers who share their time and insights with us. We wouldn't have a show without them. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.w.combeatingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiion.
好吧，Shankar Vedantam，非常感谢你今天与我交谈。这真是一种极大的荣幸。很高兴能和你在一起。谢谢你，Kim。我是心理学家和美国心理学会（APA）所做的一切的忠实粉丝，我非常感谢许多与我们分享时间和见解的科学家和研究人员。没有他们，我们就不会有这个节目。你可以在我们的网站 www.speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Stitcher 或任何你获取播客的地方找到《Speaking of Psychology》之前的剧集。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《Speaking of Psychology》由 Lee Winerman 制作。我们的声音编辑是 Chris Condayan。
Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是 Kim Mills。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。